puts the fire out so let's see some more
gaseous co2 okay so we're gonna do the
experiment today that Martin Polikoff
has been on us to do for a while so we
finally finally gonna get it get around
to doing it so now you can see the
phosphorus sitting inside a glass flask
but this time the London organizers have
revealed their mascot which you can see
on the screen behind me so got a nice
green color which point stick around for
long
we're here in turin in italy i don't
expect it to be quite so Wow a real
first for me I've never met anybody
who's discovered an element now usually
this hitting in the vacuum box and you
don't fear it's just a tiny speck in
there for less than a milligram and yet
that will be enough easily to kill a
human being so I got a parcel this
morning I think I know what's in it but
I'm not sure and I'm quite excited
because actually that's the true colors
of uranium
same
today I'm going to tell you about the
secret mark which shows if somebody is a
properly initiated chemist so here we
have some sugar common or garden
supermarket sugar we're holding to the
data on the internet the world's cup has
five kilos of gold in it and so it must
be Hollow
so once again I've managed to decimate
as I rotate this filter over the sample
of caravel I've been away for a few days
and came back to find that Prince
William is engaged and as soon as we see
something like that it's an excuse for
chemistry I'm dr. John noses I'm
climbing Wales is highest mountain I'm
gonna head up there I'm here in India in
Mumbai what used to be called Bombay the
reaction started we now have a column of
carbon
well the Asian science camp and one of
the speakers is Professor Richard Ernst
the Nobel Prize winner and it's great
opportunity for me and Brady to talk to
him
the periodic table is a hundred microns
long 50 high we could get a million of
those periodic tables onto one of these
post-it notes inserted the cube into the
periodic table of the elements to the
chemist I'd like to give him lifetime
now this is one of my favorite lumps of
matter in the world and our overall
winner is catcher Theo tonin who had a
really subtle poster based on the film
et